ever since the afc championship game and
into the run-up to the super bowl
there's been a lot of talk about
deflated footballs and in particular to
what degree can the pressure of a
football go down to what degree can it
get deflated based on temperature
differentials from where it was inflated
to where it is actually played
especially if it's inflated in a warmer
environment say indoors and then it's
played outdoors in a colder environment
and so to think about this we'll take
out our most or one of my one of my
favorite laws or equations the ideal gas
law
and it tells us that pressure times
volume is equal to the
number of molecules of our ideal gas
we're dealing with it's measured in
terms of moles but it's just a measure
of the number of molecules times our
ideal gas constant times our temperature
or if we just want to rearrange it and i
do want to rearrange it because i just
want to solve for p here we can divide
both sides by v and we would be left
with
p
is equal to
n
rt
over v
now let's think about the exact case of
what happened with the new england
footballs or what the argument is for
why they might have deflated naturally
why there might not be foul play
the argument is as well maybe they were
inflated indoors
they were inflated indoors
where the temperature is just room
temperature so roughly
degrees fahrenheit which is roughly
24 degrees celsius and in order to apply
the ideal gas law we'd want to convert
it to kelvin so this is approximately
kelvin that's the indoor temperature so
if we're inflated here
so we're inflated
if we are inflated indoors
inflated
over here and then we play outdoors and
then we play
play outdoors
where the temperature
is roughly 50 degrees fahrenheit and
that from what i've read is actually the
the temperature on the field during the
new england game
50 degrees fahrenheit which is
approximately 10 degrees celsius which
is approximately 283
283 kelvin so the argument being made is
look you have this temperature drop and
so could that temperature drop if this
temperature drops by a certain percent
could that account for the pressure drop
that was actually measured and the
pressure drop that was actually measured
was a pressure drop gauge pressure and
this is an important point because it
was glossed over in some of the initial
analyses
the gauge pressure indoors where the
ball was inflated is 12.5 or was 12.5
pounds per square inch and the gauge
pressure outdoors where the balls were
felt like they were deflated somehow or
had less pressure was
10.6 pounds per square inch
so to see if if these numbers are
consistent with each other or consistent
with no foul play let's simplify our
ideal gas law a little bit make it a
little bit particular for this
circumstance
so in this circumstance we're going to
assume no foul play if we assume no foul
play that means no air is let into or
out of so the number of molecules aren't
going to change the ideal gas constant
obviously it shouldn't change it's just
it's a universal gas constant so this
this should be constant
and then our volume let's just assume
the football it's made out of leather
it's relatively rigid it's volume might
have changed a little bit but for the
sake of our analysis we'll say that it
pretty much held up its shape so its
volume stayed constant as we went from
indoors to outdoors so to simplify this
equation let's just call all of this
stuff in green let's just call that k if
you take your n multiply it times r
divided by v that's just equal to some
constant called k
so we can simplify all of this
to
all of this can be simplified to p
pressure in this case should be some
constant
should be some constant
times temperature some constant
times temperature because once again
we're assuming volume doesn't change
we're assuming no air is let in or out
so when you look at it this way any
percent change on temperature should
have the same percent change in pressure
so let's see if the change in in
temperature the percent change is
consistent with the percent change in
pressure that was actually observed
and so when we look at the temperature
we should be doing it in kelvin so we
should look at
we should look at this change right over
here going from 297 kelvin to 283 kelvin
so what is the drop here let's see it's
a change of it's a drop of 14 kelvin let
me get my calculator out
so
it's a drop of 14 kelvin 14 kelvin and
we started at 297
so divided by
gets us
a
roughly a let's just say if we round to
the nearest percentage
0.047 that's roughly a 5 drop
so this is
so this right over here
is a five
percent
five percent drop and i'll write
approximately five percent drop and i'll
see what the drop in pressure is
so
this is going from 12.5 psi to 10.6 psi
that's
1.9 psi drop
so it's 1.9 psi drop divided by our
start which is 12.5
12.5
which looks like a 15.2
percent drop or roughly 15 percent drop
so this looks like a
so things are starting to look shady
this looks like a 15
15 to drop and this is actually what
some of the initial analyses what they
did and they said oh look something
clearly shady happened because
temperature by itself could only should
only account for a five percent drop in
pressure but there was a 15 drop in
pressure so that would today maybe some
air was let out somehow
but there was actually a mistake in that
initial analysis gage pressure the 12.5
psi that's actually not the absolute
pressure what gauge pressure is a
measure of what gage pressure is a what
gauge pressure is a measure of is how
much more pressure you have inside than
outside outside the ball you do have
pressure standard atmospheric pressure
it might change depending on the weather
etc but there is pressure the pressure
is caused by the weight of the
atmosphere so in order to figure out
absolute pressure and to figure out the
correct percentage change you need to
add the how much more pressure there is
inside the ball to what the outside
pressure is and i don't know the exact
readings for that day at in in new
england but the standard the standard
pressure is 14 standard atmospheric
pressure is 14.7 psi so plus
14.7 psi
it gets us to what is this 27.2
psi
and if we add the 14.7 over here once
again to get the true absolute pressure
once again the gauge reading is just how
much pressure inside the football then
outside so if you want the true pressure
the absolute pressure you add these and
this is going to be 25.2
25.2 psi
now we can calculate the actual
percentage drop and compare it to this
five percent drop so let's see we still
have a one we still have oh actually
minor mistake this is 25.3 don't want to
make a little arithmetic error here 25.3
psi so we still have the same drop we
have a 1.9 psi drop to go from 27.2 to
25.3 but it's over a larger base so it
should be a lower percentage and let's
calculate what that is so we have 1.9
psi drop
divided by 27.2 psi 27 27.2
is equal to
it's a little under a seven percent drop
so it looks like
approximately a seven percent drop
now these two things are not exact but
they are a lot closer and this degree
you're like okay they might have been
other factors at play maybe some of the
measurements weren't done exactly right
maybe actually the ambient pressure was
somehow different inside and outside
there's also some possibility that if
especially when you're outside if some
water if some
precipitation is on the ball as that
precipitation evaporates it might cool
down the ball further
which would drop the pressure even more
so this isn't definitive but at least
the numbers here when we apply the ideal
gas law properly they they pretty much
account for most of the pressure drop so
at least here i you know i wouldn't get
too caught up in in all of the uh
conspiracy theories